everyone who are you
I hope you like good food I know it's
the session after food so usually you
are digesting so I'm gonna try to wake
you up
um so thanks for all coming here I'm
with Jane from Baxter if you want to say
hi I'm Pierre I'm the CEO of under table
um what I'm gonna show you today it's
the work of the Jinky methodology seal
with maintaining and the pepper mill
repo that maybe you might be aware of if
you work with Jupiter networks and
Orchestra Jupiter notebooks
um so we're gonna showcase the work we
have done and what we have done in the
open source repo as well which will help
you to replicate that walkthrough for 95
of what we're gonna showcase and five
percentages using our UI to render the
The Notebook so we're gonna see in the
tutorials but the part of the workflow
and the use of the SDK is completely
open source engine you can Revenue
through how to set that up as well and
understand each step of what happens
um so we're gonna just have two or three
slides to set the context but really
jump into the work the workshop as fast
as we can and have a long session of
creating after questions
I think that's the best setup
I mean I'm only gonna spend 10 seconds
on that slide but the the main use case
and paint contractual that I call is
when you
um create or maintain data pipelines you
have a lot of Errors for many reasons
um can be a data drift can be just typo
can be someone who changed an input or
dependency you have errors basically
adjustment to debug and it can be very
comparison to debug the sellers and to
lose time to have to re-run your entire
workflow also quality to meet the
deadline to produce a report or a
dashboard or someone is now stuck
because they don't have the dependency
that they need for their own kind of
maybe add doc analysis or their own
workflow that relies on your on your on
yours so what we focused on is really
trying to think about That's a classic
experience that much usually give a talk
about when you demonstrate at Netflix
they're they're very difficult workflows
to maintain and very conversant
or you want to produce data that can be
surfacing Your solution such as Tableau
you have so many
technologies that are involved and so
many people want to maintain this
different parts
so it's very difficult for people to
collaborate or even develop an issue and
that's why we really focused on on that
thing fun
what we're going to use today we're
going to use gitbot it's optional you
can use it or you don't have to use it
but it's an easy way of watching me to
Showcase how to do the setup you're
going to use Daxter we can use paper
mill paper mill origami and norigami and
pepper Milo yummy and origami are the
the work we mainly did to enable the
workshop today and the collaboration
with Jamie here from naxter
um so I'm not going to go into more
details about those but after the
workshop
um when we have the current decision I'm
going to talk about those those thoughts
specifically and then and why we made
some decisions
um so I mean I went over that the goal
is to shorten the feedback loop to uh
basically enable live troubleshooting of
notebooks that are used as assets
this is overview of overall
um commercial architecture of notable
and Daxter and how they communicate with
each other again just to show you the
slide we can we can go back to it in the
Q a but uh for instance to give you the
review before we dive deep into it
you're gonna rely on an API keyboard
tracks version of a notebook that is
associated with a version
um setup dependency which we're gonna be
here the AdWords image and the project
files
um there is a there is notification
system in the newspaper meal to add the
two tools interact with one another
through the materialization of that
asset and also the parameters of course
so I'm gonna end over to Jamie to talk
about the Dexter side and then we're
gonna jump in on the workshop
cool so uh hi everyone uh my name is
Jamie I am a software engineer at
Elemental um and Elemental is just a
company uh developing uh Dexter
open source product and we'll
we'll say
these are notebooks
um
cool so I'm gonna be running the
workshop and in the workshop we're going
to basically just be taking a Jupiter
notebook and productionizing it as part
of a data pipeline that Jupiter notebook
is just going to do some like class
analysis of the iris
so before we get into that we'll spend
like uh 10 minutes doing like a little
like design process we'll kind of go
through
what a data pipeline is and we'll go
through designing the data pipeline that
we're going to implement
and that'll provide kind of like a nice
framework for learning about two
different paradigms of data pipelines
the task focused data Pipeline and the
asset Focus data
um and then we'll just kind of go into
like what is dagster how does that fit
into everything and we'll learn all of
the dagster apis and Concepts that will
be needed
um so we can just start off by defining
like what a data pipeline is in Broad
terms so a data pipeline is just a
series of computations that result in
some deliverables or data assets
and a data asset can be a lot of things
it could be
a table in a database an ml model some
kind of like report you distribute to
people
um and today one of the ones we're
working with is uh
so a really classic example
pipeline is the ETL pipeline
so for anyone who's kind of not super
aware of what an ETL pipeline is
basically the first step we fetch data
from some external data source
um and then we might do some
transformations to that data we might
clean it up join some data sets together
whatever we need to do
get our data into a
user and then we just store that data in
a data
so
let's start applying what we're going to
do today to this ETL
Ife so the first thing we'll need to do
is actually like fetch our Iris data set
and or something like this we could
either write custom API I called
ourselves or we could use
the light air bike which does
data ingestion without you having
and for the sake of making this kind of
data pipeline exploration and design
phase a little more like the real world
um let's assume that instead of having
like a nice canonical Ira State Set uh
that instead there's like a group of
scientists somewhere they're constantly
publishing new data about different
flower species and we want to fetch data
from that database
so that we're always kind of using like
more up-to-date data
so once we fetch our data we will
form that data set
I'm going to analyze and for that we
could use
and the last step stays pretty much the
same you just store our data over via
we have to go
um and in this case let's just say we're
starting it in school
so the last thing we need to do here is
add our Jupiter notebook into this pack
this pipe so
a lot of stuff at the very end that
fetches the data from Snowflake and
executed
um so I just want to take a little
sidebar and just say that I've
named a couple of different external
tools as part of this data pipeline
explanation and if you aren't like
familiar with all of them or any of them
um that's totally fine we're not going
to be using them part of the workshop I
just am kind of mentioning them so that
if you are familiar with them you uh
kind of can
root this data pipeline that we're
designing into some
machine or work with
before okay so now we have designed for
this data pipeline we know exactly what
tasks we need to execute and we know
where our source data is coming from and
where our data ends up
so we'll call this the task Focus data
pipeline that's sort of the main object
that we're modeling is the path
all right so let's think about what
might happen uh after we've gotten this
pipeline up and running let's say it's
running really well and soon we get a
request to analyze uh daffodils too
so we'll add more code to the stuff that
purchase the data or code to the step
that does
informations
and we'll end up with some daffodil data
in our snowflake database
uh and then maybe after that we get a
request to analyze roses too so we'll go
through that same process and add the
rose data
so uh here you can notice that um even
though we've uh we've created some new
tables and our data pipeline
pipeline responsible for handling more
data we don't really have a good way of
documenting that in the individual task
of nothing has happened to
to the way we're sort of modeling this
air byte test in our data pipeline that
tells us that now it's fetching like
three different data sets
so our tasks are responsible for
handling more data and this also means
that like bugs are going to become
harder to attract
so if our EBT Transformations fail
we're not really sure if it's because
there's a problem with the DBT models or
if there's
something wrong with the actual like
Source data set
so uh how can we fix this problem
um if we start looking a little closer
at our data pipeline we'll start to see
that it's made of more than just tasks
so each of these tasks actually produces
data assets
so our task to fetch the raw data from
the flowers database produces tables for
each data or for each species
and the data we're storing in Snowflake
is exactly the same data that comes out
of the DBT task
and finally our Jupiter notebook creates
this executed notebook file and that's
actually what we're going to be sharing
around to share our analysis
so the data sets and the jupyter
notebook in these green boxes are what
we actually kind of care about in this
data Pipeline and the actual data
objects that we'll be working with
um
if we want to like do more data analysis
or like to understand like the artifacts
that are big
so
let's try uh reconstructing this exact
same data pipeline but like focusing on
those data assets rather than the past
so the kind of like first thing to do
just kind of ground Us in this uh
exercise is we should kind of go through
our Legend and determine
determine what objects we're actually
going to
so
we'll need a way to represent our
external data source which is basically
would be our like flowers database
and then we'll need a way to represent
each of the data assets that it's
created uh throughout the data pipeline
uh we'll be connecting
um those assets edges that represent
data dependencies so
at the end of an edge yes at the end of
an edge depends on
and then we'll still want to kind of
document how those created so we'll
along the edge between assets
document the tool or like
okay
so let's break out just the iris
analysis part of the state of pipeline
first and go through the process
so we can start by touching the iris
data from the power database again we've
documented the reviews or with air byte
here
and then we can
transform that Iris data set data set
and that becomes kind of like our final
Iris data
and that data gets fed into our notebook
NXT
so when we want to add additional uh
assets to this pipeline like our
daffodil and our rows data pretty simple
really similar process
make the data assets for the uh
adaptability data and the rows data
and document how those are flowing
through
so we end up with a data pipeline that
maybe looks a little bit larger but it's
doing the exact same thing as the type
if I need model before but this one's a
lot more descriptive
the data it's processing where that data
is
and we kind of have a much better idea
of how our data relates to each other
so let's just do a quick like visual
comparison between these two pipelines
there's quite a bit going on on this
slide don't feel like you need to parse
all of it the main point is to just
demonstrate that when we model our data
pipeline based on tasks we end up with
something that looks very different from
when we model our pipeline based on the
data assets
so there are some situations where
like coach makes more sense or it's like
the correct design decision uh but a
doctor we think the majority of data
pipelines should really be asset focused
um again you know we sort of think about
it like the point of your data pipeline
is to produce this data and understand
what data you have available and so it
makes sense that those data assets are
like the primary thing you look at when
you design your data
um kind of some more motivation for that
uh if you have your your cast-based
pipeline
um they're sort of this like increase in
um cognitive burden and what you have
the pipeline in order to
what data do you have available
uh because no
[Music]
um
uh like what data you have you actually
have to like dive into the definition of
so when you want to add some new data
you have to go back into your pipeline
potentially relearn what it's doing if
you forgot last time you did some work
um before you can actually start doing
your job and so there's like some time
loss there and just general like
inability to like easily parse and
understand
okay so how does Dexter fit into all of
this
um so Dexter provides a framework for
building and executing this asset
focused data Pipelines
Daxter additionally does support task
based data pipelines or like other
workflows
um since there are like cases where
those are needed uh but like I mentioned
before uh we sort of think asset Focus
data pipeline
pipeline stances so we're going to be
focusing primarily on that feature
so using the um
diagster apis you can create this sort
of assets expand across a bunch of
different technologies that you may be
saying in your day staff and you can
link these tools together
like nice cookies of workflow
um and additionally a daxer will kind of
reveal the assets that are already a
part of the data tools that you're using
so for example when you load a DVD
project up into dagster rather than just
seeing like a single DBT run pass each
model will become its own asset in the
graph and you can kind of see the
dependencies
so
in the workshop today like I said we're
going to be taking a Jupiter notebook
and making it part of a dagster data
pipeline so let's go over kind of like
the main Dexter concept that we'll be
working with
so the most important thing is the soft
set
and dagster we Define a software-defined
as software declaration
expected to exist
so just to remind everyone a data asset
a lot of things
tables and databases ml models files
somewhere in storage or like a Jupiter
notebook
and when you go to write a
software-defined asset in dagster you
need a combination of like three
different things so
the first thing you'll need is the name
of the asset so here we have the name of
our assets it's like Iris beta you use
this little asset decorator indexer to
um like held accessories that you're
writing an asset
and then you will also specify the names
of any Upstream assets that it depends
on so in this case we've created a
dependency which
brought Iris acid data asset and then
passing it as a dependency
kind of behind the scenes diagster can
do matching between the asset name and
the parameters that other assets
and finally
you need the python function for
updating or creating the asset
asset so
here we've got
pandas work to fetch our data set in and
then we're changing the name of the
columns and those are being stored as
two separate assets
so once you've written these assets
um you can view the resulting graph in
dag it which is dagster's UI we'll be
kind of going into tag it like as part
of the workshop so I won't dive into it
too much here but from daggit you can
materialize the asset
asset and when we say materialize
basically what we're saying is we're
executing the
python function
from our assets and storing the
resulting data
data so kind of a useful exercise will
be to kind of walk through what happens
when we materialize these two assets
so the first thing doctor's going to do
is
raw Irish data doesn't have any Upstream
it doesn't need any parameters
so we'll execute that first
so I'm going to run Candace call return
the value and then save that value in a
persistent location
by default that's
your local file system that you can set
it up to be like ECS or
sorry not ECS s30 or GCS
or snowflake or all depends on other
locations
okay
so then Dr is going to see that you
brought IRS data asset has and
materialized which means that the iris
data option dependencies have been built
and it can run now
so again this is kind of where Something
dixter Magic happens
in parameter for the iris beta asset uh
matches the name of the other asset that
we've defined
and so it will load the data from the
persistent location
Irish data in
and then it will additionally store that
data into a persistent
okay
so like storing in a persistent location
is actually like kind of quite important
here
um and that's because if we decide we
want to materialize these two as again
uh Dexter is going to like overwrite the
data
so it's storing in the same location
every single time
um there's some kind of nice benefits to
this uh one is that if we want to like
manually go in and inspect the data we
know the exact location
so there's no more like going into some
bucket of files and trying to parse like
which one has the most recent data
data and then another benefit of this is
that we can also tell daxer to just
materialize one asset
so if we only wanted to re-materialize
the iris beta asset
what Dax was going to do
fetch the data that we've previously
stored Iris data asset and then use that
data in our function
store the output again
okay so Dexter also has like built-in
support for working with notebooks and
we do this with a library called dagster
mail
Dexter Mill is just like a thin wrapper
around
and this allows us to execute Jupiter
notebooks as part of your data Pipelines
so instead of like maybe doing a bunch
of development work in your Jupiter
notebook and having to like copy paste
that into python functions uh you can
just run the Jupiter notebook as part of
your data pipeline
um and then you can also just like
connect your Jupiter notebook to assets
that are already in your pipeline so you
don't have to like rewrite
um
like the fetching or like data loading
logic
there are also some like additional kind
of nice features we'll see them when we
get into the workshop
um or like additional metadata and like
lineage tracking and you can view your
notebooks directly and tag it without
you start a kernel
okay so we're gonna get into the
workshop portion
um I need just one minute to
the new file and then
get started if you want to put your
laptop out and then
all right good
um all right so like I mentioned we're
going to be going through this process
of productionizing a future notebook as
part of our data pipeline uh and more
specifically we're going to be doing
like a simplified version of the data
pipeline we just designed
design so
we'll only be creating two assets one
for our jupyter notebook and one for the
iris data set
um since we're working directly with
like the canonical Iris data we just
need to fetch that data we don't need to
do any like
so that kind of Skips that middle step
um so our Jupiter notebook will take the
iris data status input and then do our
analysis
so for each step in the workshop
basically I'll talk through what we're
going to do I'll demo it up here on my
computer
um and then I'll go back to a slide that
has like all the steps you'll need to
complete and we can wait like three to
five minutes kind of depending
uh I don't know how much we're doing
because of that stuff and get everyone
speed if you run into any issues just
feel free to call me over here or babies
right there and we all sorted out
during the first step that we'll get to
in just a second
so we'll be like downloading some code
and with that you'll also have you need
that has all of the steps you'll need to
complete
and you also get like a completed
version of the workout so you're the
kind of person who just wants to like
listen uh still wants to see the final
version of the code and maybe play
around with it a little bit you'll be
able to do that
all right so we should get ourselves set
up with virtual environments so we don't
have any like dependency conflicts or
run into like I don't know Annoying like
python package issues
so to do that I'll be using the tool
called git pod
um this sort of just like create a fresh
python environment for you that you can
work with your browser
um if you're up to trying that out I
highly recommend it
get us all uh working on like the same
base it'll be kind of easier to uh I
don't know debug any issues since we
have some on the ground but if you're
more comfortable working with like
another virtual environment tool like
like um
the only requirement is that you use
it so
you can use git pod eventually you'll
kind of get dropped into what looks like
a vs code editor
um and once you get there we're all set
to go
hang out here
until we get there
foreign
thank you
okay
uh okay just give me a quick check in
does anyone want some more time
okay cool
all right so the next thing we're going
to do is get our uh Workshop code
downloaded and get um all of the
dependencies we need installed
so
in git pod there's a terminal that opens
up here otherwise you can
and I'm gonna just type
the
commands to get all the dependencies
it's all up here so you can see that
you see them here and then I'll go back
to
back so I'm just going to upgrade the
PIP just
listen for everyone
um and then we need to install dagster
uh dagster comes with this project CLI
that lets us uh kind of like install
like uh you know like official or like
well maintained uh
man and that's the name of the folder
that will be create
and then the last couple of commands are
just going in there and then
installing the dependencies
oh yeah
there we go yeah absolutely
okay
oh
all right does anyone want a little more
time to get through those commands or
all right let's move on
all right so let's do just like a little
tour of everything that we've downloaded
here so
in our director notable uh demo folder
we have these have two subs cribe
the finished folder is where you'll find
like the completed version of this
project so if you want to get like that
preview into what we'll be doing or just
kind of see the final version of code
that's where you'll go
we have the readme here that has all of
the steps if you want to just like
follow along with them there
and then in the tutorial template folder
we've got subfolders
the first one of note is this notebooks
folder
in here
got the Jupiter notebook that we'll be
working with
I recommend just like opening this
folder and getting kind of like saved
your you should see this comment at the
top
that will be like filling it out as part
of Workshop
you don't see that you might be in
and then the other file will need is
you should see a bunch of commented out
code and that's because we're not going
to be doing a bunch of
like code scratch it falls
presenting code up here and then you
have a type
of type so instead we're just gonna be
like uncommenting code Snippets and I'll
be walking through what they all do
um so you'll still get like a good
understanding of what's going
on yeah so you can get both of those
files opened up
um
imagine opening those won't take very
long so I'm just gonna hop on to the
next thing
um which is basically I'm just kind of
like walk through
Jupiter because additionally We're not
gonna be doing a ton of
work so
uh kind of like I mentioned before we're
just doing some like analysis of the
classic Iris data set
um if you're familiar with the irises
that you know already familiar with the
type of analysis we're doing in here but
basically
fetch the data set
you start kind of exploring that data
set maybe doing something
like analysis plotting so at the
beginning we're just kind of like
looking at what kind of what the data
set looks like
and then here we'll start making some
plot
I'm actually going to start executing
but you don't need to execute locally
unless you're behind
so yeah we're gonna
start looking at what the notebook is up
to or what the data set looks like
I started making plots where we're
comparing different dimensions the data
set
none
the Box plus exclusive thing
because absolutely
and then we get into our actual like
candies analysis where we're going to
try and extinguish the different um
so we do our analysis and then we're
going to do some plotting to look at our
results
we end up with this plot
what our Irish species are getting like
mustard
okay so that's our notebook uh let's get
into writing some actual code
so we're gonna go back to this edit file
that was in the assets folder again you
should see this little comment at the
top so you're going you're in the right
place
and the first thing we're going to do is
scroll down a bit to where there is a
two one con
and all we're going to do is uncomment
that's underneath it
and this last line should stay commented
we'll get to that in
so you should end up with
the block that looks like that
so what's going on here
is that we're trying to make an asset
from our Jupiter notebook that we were
just like looking at
um and this you know maybe looks a
little different from a sort of way of
defining assets that we went
oh so we were defined it more like that
you might expect to see
a block of code like this where we find
the name of the asset we give it that
asset
asset you execute a bunch of code in the
function and we return our execute
it uh the problem with this is that
actually executing the notebook is quite
complicated there's a lot of work to be
done and so we created this helper
function to find the external asset to
do it all for you so what this function
is doing
notebook you want to execute
the name you want to give your asset and
a couple other parameters we'll talk
about in a second
and it you know creates this asset and
returns it
I'll leave this
copied up here
just
to find the external asset function
so yeah the one parameter so far that I
haven't talked about is this group name
um and this is just sort of like an
organizational feature uh when we get
into dag it all
show it a little more but it just lets
you group different assets together
um like these assets are related to each
to each other
I will hang out here for a minute and
then we'll move on
okay
okay how's everyone doing did you move
on does anyone want
all right great
um
all right so let's get into actually
like executing
all right
um okay I can actually get into uh
executing these
past materializing them uh so to do that
we need to launch baggit which is
dagster's UI so to do that
from your terminal
you can just type the command
and then hit enter
if you're using gitpod it's going to pop
up this little dialogue about opening
Port 3000 and then there will be an open
browser button you can click that if
you're working more locally it prints
out this
blog statement saying serving app
for three thousand eight and you just
navigate there in your browser
to open
Okay so
thank you
all right so uh this is kind of like
your landing page for diet
um this is kind of what we call the
timeline view it uh will show you sort
of like the historical runs of any like
asset materialized or any like cat based
uh work you've done and show you whether
it's like succeeded or failed uh since
we haven't run anything yet uh this is
totally empty so
if we go up here to this kind of left
hamburger menu button or hamburger menu
button in the top left and open that up
uh we got kind of our left side panel
and here we see kind of like our two uh
sort of dagster Repository
we have um it actually repository is
just like your collection of
objects we have one for the finished
version of the tutorial and one for the
template version
um so again if you're interested in just
kind of like seeing what we're getting
to moving forward you can flip around in
the Finish tutorial uh but to see the
code we've actually been working on
little arrow the template tutorial and
open
um there's this pink notable job in here
this is you can kind of ignore it for
now it is for later just to help in case
we have any like
you can ignore this for now and then we
can be under the asset groups kind of
like menu subdivision we have our
template tutorial group
so you can click on that the template
tutorial group name comes from
cassette in our in our assets
click on that we get to this uh sort of
asset for attribute and we can see all
the assets that are parked
right now we just have
so from here uh click on this asset and
get this little right side menu
after we've materialized it this will be
populated with some more metadata that
we might find interesting
but for now we get a little description
of what's going on where the notebook is
located
and we can view our source notebook
okay
so to actually go ahead and materialize
or execute this notebook we'll go up
here to the materialize button
and we just click on it
and then this little alert will pop up
with a view button if this alert goes
away before you have the chance to click
on it you can also click on this little
hash that appears at the bottom
so yeah I missed it so I'm gonna go over
here
and this will open up a new tab that
contains all the logs from executing
your notebook
so we can sit here and we can kind of
like watch everything come in and we can
see that our notebook executes
successfully
uh once we've done that we can just exit
out of this tab
and
a right side panel for the asset we get
new metadata entries
and we actually get a metadata entry for
click that button and
The Notebook is actually
and the reason we can do that is because
like behind the scenes uh when Daxter is
executing your notebook it isn't like
overwriting the source notebook that we
wrote It's like executing that notebook
with paper mill and then writing that
executed notebook to a new location so
you can use the executed version of your
notebook and then still go look at
so give you a minute to just go through
like materializing your growing up the
first time
okay that was the same we need more time
okay let's move on then so
let's take a look at our notebook
so we have our notebook executing as an
asset
last semester but we're still fetching
our Iris data set as like the first
thing we do
and we want to kind of pull this data
fetching step out of the notebook
s or asset
um and we want to do that for a couple
of reasons uh the first one is that
uh by kind of like refactoring the Irish
data set out of the notebook it'll let
us reuse it in like future analysis so
if later we come in and we want to do
you know make a second notebook that
does other analysis we can reuse that
same Iris asset and we don't have to
like rewrite our data affection logic
um and the second reason is that it'll
allow us to use some of dagsters like
built-in functionality around like
re-materializing assets so once we've
materialized the iris data set once we
can just repeatedly materialize our
Jupiter notebook asset and it'll like
keep fetching on the data that we
already fetched for the IRS so that can
help you like reduce like I O costs
you're like making an expensive
so let's go through the process of
making an asset for our Iris data set
and getting it set up
um as like an upstream dependency for
our notebook
so to do that we're back in the init
file an assets folder
and we're going to scroll it to the top
where there's this due to label
and we're just going to uncomment this
code block here
and what's going on here looks a lot
more like the um asset declaration that
we went over in the presentation we've
got our
our asset decorator the name of the
asset and the function corporate
again we're putting the slow group name
here just for organization and uh
saying that like this Iris data set
asset uh belonged to the same group has
been overcast
all right and then the next thing we
need to do is actually tell dagster to
use
the iris data set asset as input to our
Jupiter notebook
and so if you scroll down that's where
this ends parameter comes
we'll uncomment this line
and what's Happening Here is based
space uh when Daxter goes to materialize
all these
things and it's going to say oh I need
to provide an input variable named Iris
and the value of that variable needs to
be the value of the iris babycent asset
so it's going to then like fetch the
data store for the IRS data set asset
and provide it as an iris variable in uh
like to The Notebook
and we'll get through the actual like
step of like the final step of getting
it you know
all right we need to move on
okay
uh so the last thing we need to do
before we can get back to materializing
this is update our jupyter notebook um
to accept like an injected parameter
from the actual
so again behind the scenes Bagster is
using Paper Mill and paper mill allows
you to
inject external values into your
tubes and the way paper mill does that
is by looking for cell a cell with the
tag parameters on it it deletes that
cell and then replaces it with a cell
that injects the parameter
and so what we want to do is
instead of fetching the iris data set in
our notebook we want paper mill to
delete that cell and inject a new cell
that will load the value of our Iris
creative set asset that we already
material
so typically what you would do is you
would go into your Jupiter notebook
editor you would just add a parameter
but the git pod editor doesn't let you
add cell tags so we have a chat or a
cell here that we've already tagged with
parameters
and so we're just going to cut the code
from the cell
and put it in this cell
a little bit of a different like
workload here but it's not too bad and
then you can just go ahead and delete
this note
okay how's it going let's move on
um so in
The Notebook
um it just has this comment saying that
it's been tagged with parameters you
don't actually see the parameter
parameter this screenshot is taken from
like a local vs code editor
uh you don't get to see the actual tag
it's there I promise it's there
um but we just have to put this comment
here instead
I can take a look
okay
yeah
um
all right yeah as long as your code is
in the cell with the comment saying it's
impacted parameters you should be good
to go
uh okay let's move on to materialize
so we can go back
there you'll need to click this reload
definitions button up here and this
basically tells director to go look
pull in any
so we will reload definitions and then
we should see our Iris data set asset
pop-up
and again we have this
our Jupiter notebook needs the output of
the iris data set
in order to run and that's because
so again when we execute this um
first actor is going to materialize the
iris data set and it's going to use
paper mill to delete that parameter cell
in the future notebook and insert a new
cell that will load
um the value of the iris data
so we can go ahead and click materialize
all that'll materialize both of the
assets here
and we'll click View and then we'll
watch this uh
all right here we go so our notebook has
executed successfully
if we go back here and we click on the
executed notebook notebook button uh we
can actually see the cell that tags are
injected
um you don't need to understand what's
going on here it's like
dragster internal implementation stuff
um basically we're loading a parameter
Iris
and Daxter knows that that means it's
the IRS data set
again quickly scroll through
all right I'll give you a minute to go
through all that if you run into any
issues like definitely let me know
all right we're doing good
cool all right so
let's just like quickly take a look at
what we've done here uh We've basically
designed our data pipeline
we have our Iris data set asset and
we're using that as input for inputer
Notebook and we're materializing both of
those and getting our
executed notebook assets
that share around to anymore
so we're going to shift here a little
bit and start talking
um about notable and using a notable
notebook in this pipeline
first thing we'll need to keep that is
make a notebook
um but it will count it's free
um
you can go through the rest of this
particular or you can just like watch
along and see what works
foreign
yeah
um yeah how's that going I know like
signing up for Stuff
connecting another verification but if
we're good to move on um
we do that
um
okay
there's like a little bit more setup we
need to do before we can uh
materializing uh like the first one is
we actually need to get our notebook
notable so if you're working locally you
already have your notebook on your
computer but if you're in get pod will
need to actually like download The
Notebook so to do that
you can just find our notebook in the
left sidebar and if we right click on it
we'll get this download button
we'll do that and it'll download
and then we'll have it for uploading to
them notable
and to do that
when you open up notable you should have
this sort of like space that you land in
if you aren't there you put the notable
icon in the top left and it'll bring you
back to that space
um kind of the default project that
should be made for you is called my
first project so we can click into that
and then click the upload button and
upload our notebook
and then once we've done that we can um
open this in a new tab so we have like
easy access
um
all right is everyone done uploading our
notebook did you move on
cool all right so last sort of setup we
need to do
um if you need to get an API token from
notable so that our tags for code can
talk to notable
so to do that
in your main notable page click
on profile
settings
select menu there's an API token
's page and then you can create a new
key and then just copy that value
and then we'll go back to
iPod or whatever terminal you're using
using here we want to curl C and fill
the dag it process
and then we're going to create an
environment variable for our notable
so export the name of the environment
variable should be notable underscore
token
through equal sign and then copy in the
value of the API token
um
that you copy it from
no I've already set mine up for this
and then once you've done that
again
all right let's move on to the next step
uh so now we can actually go into okay
more another minute having issue
foreign
okay cool let's move on
okay so yeah so we need to get
um a dragster asset set up that will
actually like execute this notable
notebook so we'll go back to gitpod
go back to our init file where we find
all of our other assets
and down at the bottom we've got some
more code for you to uncomment
and this time uh we're using the paper
mill origami library with The Bagster
integration
a notable like that Jurassic so this
looks really similar to the diagonal
asset we planned before we just give it
the name we want the asset to have we're
setting up our inputs we have the group
name the only thing that's different is
this notebook ID
and to uh if a notebook ID we'll get
that from the notable notebook we
uploaded and just
pattern
[Music]
you kind of have a little close to time
uh we're good to move on
yeah we're gonna do that after
that
yeah unless anyone's still working on
this we can move on to the notebook baby
stuff
okay so to get the notebook ID we just
want to go back to the notebook that we
uploaded to notable and then up here in
the URL bar there's like this
string of numbers and letters and we're
just going to copy that
and set that as our GoPro
right cool let's move on to there
all right
um
all right so now we're back to being
able to materialize everything
okay go back to tag it
again we want to hit the reload
definitions button so we can reload all
of our assets
and we'll see our notable asset pop up
down here
so we want to materialize
the iris data set asset and the kidneys
notable notebook asset so to do that we
can uh hold down the shift key
and click on both of them
and then the materialize selected button
will just materialize the choosing
okay our view button
and project
so once our notebook starts execute
execution get a link
a notable notebook to watch the
activation happens so kind of behind the
scenes notable similar to uh
Dexter is like making
a book and then executing that so you
retain like a version of The Source
notebook that you can go in and edit and
change
the historical executed
um yeah so there's like a view button
alert that pops up if you don't see that
you can click on this little like hash
down here in the bottom corner
and then that should open up a new tab
that has this book
great
um so then in the logs you'll see um
and a link click that and then we can
like watch our notebook process
[Music]
here we are
and then once your notebooks executed
all the way through you have this sort
of like artifact or like link that you
can share out
so let's hang out here for a minute and
then move on to like the very last thing
we'll do uh which will be like some live
debugging
um and hopefully that'll happen pretty
quick and we have
some so
we're good to move on
um
to actually like
debug a notebook here we have to like
introduce an error so we'll do something
really simple
we'll go back to
notebook we want to do the like original
like Source notebook not the notebook we
just
uh but here in our original Source
notebook we can
roll down a couple cells I'm going to
insert a cell right after this Iris
describe now
and we'll just raise an exception
and uh I just want to like make sure
this notebook's safe so we can
add like wait a couple seconds to uh
it's working
and then we can um go back to bag it and
we'll materialize everything
hang out here
[Music]
materialization
foreign
all right
so
what we'll do is um similar to what
we've been doing before we'll go back to
Dag it we'll materialize the asset
and uh
this time we can kind of just like wait
for our notebook to fail because we know
it's going to fail because we wrote that
exception in there
so we'll wait for that to fail and then
we'll kind of like investigate like what
that debugging Globe looks like
so
maybe a more like real world example of
this is like you might have this
notebook executing on a schedule
um like built-in like schedule
functionality so maybe you have this set
up to run
yeah every hour every once a day or
whatever and you get an alert that your
notebook you want to go in you want to
see what's
right so we're gonna wait for our
notebook to fail and then we can click
on the link for a notebook that's going
to open up like a live version
all of the cells up to where the error
happened are still executed like those
values are still alive
to get and explore them and then we'll
be able to figure out what the error is
fix it and execute the notebook
um
just wait here for the personal steps
and then we'll get into that process
there we go okay so we get our stack
trace and dagget it's a general idea of
what's going on but we can scroll up and
we can click the link into our notable
notebook
and we can see uh kind of what all of
the executed cells up until this point
you can still
this data
investigate
uh the Irish data set again like already
loaded into the kernel like it's good to
go and we can just fix our issue and
execute the rest of the notebook
um yeah and that's like basically all
we're doing in the workshop okay
so we can uh in the last like a couple
of minutes we had left
what questions you guys have
um and since we don't have that much
time you have any like all
uh feel free to email me freaking email
Dave
or if you want to uh join the Dr Slack
Channel you can ask questions there as
well our engineers
okay
[Laughter]
um I mean that's like a much larger
discussion uh I would highly recommend
like maybe going through like our dark
site and looking at some of the content
we have
pictures of Dexter I would say like the
main distinguishing
approach to
data workflows or like give you a lot
like better insight into like the data
you're actually working with
um but yeah again uh I would say that's
like you have a lot of content on our
Docs
a Blog uh kind of addressing like
the ways we think like doctor approaches
is sort of like larger data
orchestration space
um
of the workbook
s
um no you definitely could do your like
iterate a lot of like your initial like
development and duration in the notebook
um like the whole point is that like you
could do
a lot of your development in The
Notebook
and then you set that into the factory
pipeline uh you might do that like a
little refactor step
but like the process of like building a
notebook would be like really good it is
like
pick up and drop it in and then
okay
so you don't have to run
shooting
okay
um no so you I mean so
I'll just take a step back so Dexter we
have like our open source
but scheduling is available every
everywhere
um
I
won't like get into the actual like code
right now but basically there's just
like another decorator you can
you can apply to like a python function
you'd say like uh be like at schedule
you give it some values of like how
often you want it to run and then you
just basically like tell it what assets
you want to materialize or like what
other like tasks you want to kick off
um and then that becomes part of your
like Bagster like project or repository
this like collection of objects and then
in the
did I get UI
there's like a uh
there's like a tab four schedules and
you can see
um
we're not really set up to run schedules
right now but yeah
yeah
I actually don't know
um
yeah I'm not sure
yeah no there's a lot of debate over
actually that what it actually is is
like an octopus or a squid
yeah I don't actually know what
um all right yeah thank you all so much